just discovered that i may have a son
here in this land how much child support
is she getting from the king pays no
child support
no time support for 30 years and you
came back
use a dummy
here hello i am nakeem jaffe king of
zumunda
he's supposed to be like the prince of
wakanda wakanda is a fictional place not
everybody so munda is a very real nation
i don't need no handouts
wait a minute all right i'm gonna go
back okay
resenting king hakeem's son from america
and my mom's and his moms
children this is your brother hey kwan
i'm sorry i slept with your man this
happened before we even met
it's not like you're the first man i've
ever been with
what did you just say about the other
men coming to america now he's coming
to me i always thought that mika was
going to be queen
a woman isn't allowed to lose amunda
it's the law did it ever occur to you
that megan wanted to be your heir
would you dare banish me from my own
bedroom
you must be strong and general izzy
would love nothing more than to take
over zamunda raise it higher
put your hands together like that say it
again
i must admit your style is far into my
kingdom but it's impressive
that's right there you go let me hear
you say hey ho hey ho
no don't do that that's his mother oh
don't you say no not to his mother
nephew
coming to america now it's coming to me
you